Hello ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's das wohl s-...sta...
(H: Krasseste Rezept!)
Oh mein Gott!
Das Rezept ist so krass, dass mir die Worte fehlen!
Das hab ich ja noch nie gehabt!
(H: Das krasseste Rezept!)
Das...das ist echt das krasseste Rezept ever!
Es gibt den San Sebastian Cheesecake!
Was das ist erkläre ich euch jetzt denn viele kennen den noch gar nicht.
Die, die ihn Istanbul waren, kennen den mit Sicherheit.
Da gibt's ein Café, da stehen die Leute Schlange und ziehen sogar Nummern,
um ihren San Sebastian Cheesecake zu kriegen.
Und wir waren ja dieses Jahr 2 Mal in Istanbul.
Bei meiner zweiten Istanbulreise
(H:  Letztes Jahr!)
Letztes Jahr, 2019 sind wir nachts kilometerlang
durch Istanbul gelaufen und haben dieses einzige Café, wo es das gibt -
mittlerweile gibt's bestimmt schon mehrere - entdeckt und haben den probiert.
Und ich füg euch gerne mal die Insta Stories ein.
H: Und wir haben uns jetzt hier diesen San Sebastian - den berühmten San Sebastian Cheesecake gegönnt.
H: Den haben wir von hier. Der Laden ist rappelvoll, man kommt da nur mit Reservierung rein.
H: Guck mal, direkt vorm Galata Turm, geil!
H: Schmeckt wie Pudding!
K: Wir haben den San Sebastian Cheesecake gefunden nach 5300km!
K: Und wir sind auch nicht alleine, Yusuf und Shirin sind auch dabei, die haben wir hier kennengelernt.
Und ich hab noch nicht probiert, ich hab erstmal gehört, was die anderen sagen.
Und wir waren einfach hin und weg, ne?
Es war richtig lecker, Hamza! Erzähl doch mal!
Erzähl auch mal ein bisschen was!
(H: Was soll ich erzählen? Das war einfach der leckerste Kuchen, den ich je in meinem Leben gegessen habe!)
Jaa!
(H: Der ist besser gewesen als du den je gemacht hast!
Aber, ich muss da jetzt sagen: du hast den ja schon ausprobiert, den San Sebastian Cheesecake hier.)
Ja!
(H: Und der war 1 zu 1 gleich!)
1 zu 1! Also ich habe die Augen geschlossen und dachte:
Ey, du bist grade am Galata Turm in Istanbul in dieser Gasse und probierst grad den
New York Cheese - ach, den San Sebastian Cheesecake!
Freud'scher Versprecher weil mein Lieblings Cheesecake war immer de New York Cheesecake.
Die, die mich kennen, wissen das. Und jetzt, San Sebastian Cheesecake hat das einmal getoppt.
(H: Also grob gesagt: Warum reden wir so viel?)
Warum reden wir so viel? Weil das ein besonderes Video ist, einfach.
Und lecker ist.
(H: Der Kuchen ist einfach geil!)
Der ist einfach geil!
So, jetzt ist es raus.
Ich hab für euch experimentiert, also so sieht das aus, wenn ich Rezepte entwickle!
Ja, Original! Und..
(H: Der hat überall Flecken.)
Ja, das ist halt weil ich das immer nebenbei dabei hatte, ich hab immer so ein bisschen:
"Nein, doch ein Ei! Nein, die Eier müssen 250g betragen!"
(H: Jetzt ist auch die Frage geklärt, wo die die Rezepte immer her hast. du machst das selber!
Ja, ich mach die immer selber.
Und ja, ich hab für euch experimentiert. Und das sind auch Zutaten,
die bekommt ihr alle in ganz normalen deutschen Supermärkten.
Hier hab ich Doppelrahmfrischkäse. Bitte tut mir hier einen Gefallen und greift nicht auf die salzigen
Varianten zurück. Nehmt auch keine Light Variante oder so. Doppelrahmfrischkäse, der nicht salzig schmeckt.
Und den hab ich hier schon in meiner Küchenmaschine. Da geb ich jetzt ganz einfach Zucker mit rein.
Und dann rühren wir das mit dem Rührhaken. Da nehm ich den mit der Gummilippe,
damit der auch die Ränder schön mitnimmt.
Ungefähr 10, 15sek. Und kleiner Tipp von mir: Doppelrahmfrischkäse sowie auch alle anderen Zutaten
sollten Zimmertemperatur haben. Wenn nicht habt ihr so kleine Stückchen vom Frischkäse,
der eben nicht ganz in diese homogene Masse einhergeht.
Und daher am besten auf Zimmertemperatur haben.
So, 10-15sek, dann sehen wir uns wieder.
Bitte nicht zu lange rühren, sonst wird der Frischkäse flüssig.
Das wollen wir nicht, er darf ruhig noch fest bleiben.
Und ganz, ganz wichtig bei diesem Rezept, hier wird nichts aufgeschlagen!
Wir wollen hier keine Luft in die Masse reinschlagen, damit sie eben so cremig wie möglich ist.
Jetzt hab ich hier Speisestärke und siebe das noch hinzu, ganz wichtig:
sieben damit keine Klümpchen dabei sind!
Und ich hab auch die Mehlvariante für mich ausprobiert: hat mir nicht so gut gefallen,
bleibt auf jeden Fall lieber bei Speisestärke.
So, das einmal hineinsieben und auch nochmal ganz kurz unterrühren.
So, die zimmerwarmen Eier hab ich jetzt aufgeschlagen und einmal ganz kurz verrührt.
Hier auch ganz, ganz wichtig: nicht schlagen! Keinen Mixer oder sowas benutzen,
um da eben Luft reinzuschlagen weil das ist genau das Gegenteil, was wir möchten.
Und jetzt rühr ich das ganz langsam in die Frischkäsemasse ein.
Auf niedriger Stufe und auch nur so lange, bis sich die Eier mit dem Frischkäse verbunden haben.
Und wie immer schmecken Eier von glücklichen Hühner, die sich frei bewegen dürfen, am aller, allerbesten!
So im nächsten Schritt gebt ihr den Zitronensaft und die zimmerwarme Sahne hinein.
Und außerdem noch Vanilleextrakt. Und das Vanilleextrakt ist wirklich das aller, allerwichtigste hier am Rezept!
Denn beim San Sebastian Cheesecake ist es der Vanillegeschmack, der so dominiert.
Man hat eben auch echt das Gefühl, man beißt auf richtige Vanille und eben keine künstlichen Aromen.
Daher bitte tut mir den Gefallen und verzichtet auf Vanillinzucker.
Vanillinzucker - man hört's schon am Namen - es heißt noch nicht mal Vanillezucker
weil da keine Vanille drin ist. Das sind nur Aromen, das sind künstliche Aromen und das schmeckt man auch.
Und beim Vanilleextrakt, das bekommt ihr natürlich hier bei mir im Shop, und ist auch alkoholfrei
in der Squeezeflasche. Da sind wirklich, also da ist echte Vanille drin und das schmeckt man auch,
das sieht man auch. Und falls ihr den grad nicht da habt, weil ihr grad eben nicht online bei mir bestellt habt,
dann greift solange auf Vanillezucker zurück aber es kommt natürlich nicht an das Extrakt ran.
Und sobald das alles auch nur ganz kurz miteinander verrührt wurde, ist die Masse auch schon fertig
und kann vorbereitet werden für den Ofen.
Ich hab mich geschnitten :(
Diese kleinen Wunden tun am meisten weh!
(H: *petzt* Ja, Kiki hat auch ne Träne verdrückt!)
Ich hab auch ne Träne verdrückt. Wenn meine Augen grade glasig sind, nicht wundern!
Aber jetzt ist alles wieder gut, ich weiß ja was mich gleich erwartet!
Ein San Sebastian Cheesecake! Von daher alles gut.
Ich hab jetzt die 20cm Springfrom vorbereitet. Da müsst ihr auch drauf achten, dass der Boden
einmal ausgekleidet ist. Und ganz anders als bei meinen anderen Rezepten diesmal
auch der Rand der Springform. Also da auch nochmal Backpapier drangeben,
mit Backtrennspray oder mit Wasser in so ner Sprühflasche, könnt ihr selber entscheiden.
Ich find Backtrennspray ist da ein bisschen zuverlässiger, dann hält das auch am Rand.
Und das ist ganz wichtig, dass es eben nicht einklappt.
Und jetzt die Cheesecake Masse einfüllen und dann backen wir sie.
Ich sag euch auch schon die Backzeit, das sind diesmal 240 Grad Umluft
und das Ganze dauert dann 31 bis maximal 32 Minuten.
Und vorher einmal die Springform noch ein paar Mal auf den Boden klopfen, das zeig ich euch gleich.
Aber wir nehmen den Ton raus, das ist ziemlich laut Hamza!
Damit die Bläschen auch verschwinden.
(H: Kann ich es gleich auf den Boden klopfen?)
Wenn du willst!
(H: Gerne!)
Bisschen Aggressionen rauslassen?
(H: Ja gerne!)
(H: So, soll ich machen jetzt?)
Jaa!
(H: So?)
(H: Anheben oder...?)
Anheben und dann einfach auf den Boden plumpsen lassen!
Ah ruhig ein bisschen mehr Gewalt!
(H: Dann verschwinden die Bläschen, ne?)
Genau und die Bläschen verschwinden und das wird noch cremiger dadurch.
Übrigens braucht ihr für dieses Rezept damit ihr keinen Frust erlebt zuhause
eine absolut feste Springform, wo euch nichts ausläuft.
Meine verlinke ich euch natürlich gerne in die Infobox genauso wie alle anderen Utensilien, Zutaten sowieso!
Und dann sehen wir uns nach dem Backen wieder.
So, der San Sebastian Cheesecake ist fertig. Ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig:
direkt nach der Backzeit aus dem Ofen holen!
Sonst rate ich euch immer dazu, den Käsekuchen drin zu lassen, im Ofen auskühlen zu lassen.
Das dürft ihr hier nicht machen! Denn der San Sebastian Cheesecake lebt ja davon,
dass der Kern nicht flüssig sondern eher so richtig zart-schmelzend und weich ist.
Und jetzt müsst ihr ganz stark sein: Versprecht es mir! Lasst ihn auskühlen.
Mindestens 4h, gerne auch über Nacht. Ich lass das einfach unabgedeckt
auf Zimmertemperatur stehen und wir sehen uns in 4 Stündchen wieder!
So, nach der Kühlzeit wird jetzt einfach der Springformrand entfernt, außerdem
tu ich auch das Backpapier am Rand. Ansonsten lass ich den Kuchen jetzt da, wo er ist
denn ich bin jetzt ganz ungeduldig.
Ich will diesen San Sebastian Cheesecake jetzt einfach nur anschneiden,
um euch die Konsistenz zu zeigen.
Oah, also das Messer gleitet richtig in den Cheesecake!
(H: Also ist es völlig normal, dass der so verbrannt aussieht?)
Absolut, das ist sogar ein Muss!
(H: Nicht dass die Leute jetzt schreiben schon..)
Nein, das ist ganz normal!
(H: Jetzt kommt's, jetzt ist die...)
Stunde der Wahrheit!
(H: Mach ganz langsam Kiki, damit das richtig toll aussieht!)
Genau das ist es!
(H: Das ist es!)
Genau das!
(H: Diese Feuchte!)
Dieser feuchte Kern!
(H: Oh mein Gott!)
Perfekt! Das ist der San Sebastian Cheesecake in Perfektion.
Und was ihr jetzt machen müsst: schnappt euch einen Teller und legt ihn nicht so drauf,
sondern einmal so.
Ohh, lecker!
Und das ist er, der Original San Sebastian Cheesecake!
Und ich sag euch auch, warum der original ist:
Der San Sebastian Cheesecake zeichnet sich eben wie grad gesagt durch diesen weichen,
zart-schmelzenden Vanillekern aus. Der schmeckt so ein bisschen wie
ganz, ganz zarter Vanillepudding. Also nicht den, den ihr kennt
und den ihr anrührt un der dann fest wird.
Sondern einfach richtig zart, wie so aus Wolken gemacht!
(H: Ja Kiki, mach weiter!)
Jaa!
Auf jeden Fall ganz, ganz wichtig auch noch wichtig zu sagen, dass...wir backen ja bei sehr
heißer Temperatur, stoppen dann und nehmen ihn ja nach 30min schon raus,
was sehr unüblich ist aber dadurch haben wir eben diese harte Außenhülle.
Also hart im Sinne von einfach nur fest, also wie ein ganz normaler Käsekuchen.
Erinnert so ein bisschen an den New York Cheesecake.
Und jetzt geh ich einmal mit dem Löffel rein und...oh mein Gott!
Das ist das, was ich meine. Das ist genau das, was ich meine!
(H: *aufgeregtes Lachen*)
Und jetzt probier ich mal für euch!
(H: Ja für uns, ne?)
Für euch, natürlich!
(H: Mhm, ist klar!)
Mmmmh!
Oh mein Gott!
Die leckerste Entdeckung meines ganzen gesamten letzten Jahres!
Also ich bin ja ein Käsekuchenfreak und ich hab immer den New York Cheesecake
über alles geliebt, aber sorry, der toppt, der toppt's einfach nochmal!
Richtig, richtig lecker!
Probiert's einfach nur aus!
(H: Also wer den nicht isst, der hat was verpasst!
Der hat echt, wirklich was verpasst! Weil ich hab's euch am Anfang auch gesagt:
Ich hab mir gedacht "Was wollt ihr alle? Warum wollt ihr
alle einen verbrannten Cheesecake essen?
(H: Das hat sie wirklich immer gesagt!)
Ich hab dem Hamza die ganze Zeit gesagt: Warum schicken mir die Leute das?"
Und jetzt weiß ich warum und ich bin einfach nur froh, dass ich das entdeckt hab.
Und jetzt müsst ihr das unbedingt nachmachen.
Hamza wir gönnen uns gleich noch in aller Ruhe, ja?
Und ihr macht's unbedingt nach! Ich hab euch die genauen Mengenangaben wie immer
in die Infobox geschrieben. Unbedingt ein Abo da lassen,
es ist auch komplett kostenlos. Also wenn euch dieses Video gefallen hat,
wenn ihr mehr solche Rezepte sehen wollt, beliebte Rezepte: sagt's einfach!
Ich experimentier für euch und mach's für euch nach.
Auf jeden Fall ein Abo da lassen, genau.
Ich wünsch euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken und wir sehen uns dann
bei meinem nächsten Video!
Tschüss!
Hamza, komm! Essen, los!
(H: Endlich!)
Endlich!
Und in Istanbul war es so, dass dann drüber noch geschmolzene Schokolade gegeben wurde.
Also in meinem Fall hatte ich Vollmilchschokolade und ich muss sagen:
Mit der Vollmilchschokolade zusammen hat's geschmeckt wie ein extrem geiler Kinderriegel Kuchen!
Und ich demonstrier euch das mal.
Also wenn dann richtig!
Ohh, sieht das gut aus!
So, jetzt verabschiede ich mich aber wirklich.
Also bis bald, Tschüss!